kicks it back out pass deflected and  stolen three on one for the box  holiday fouled by booker they didn't  call it and tedecopo banks at home  that would have been his sixth foul  how do you not call that foul and if  you're devin booker how  are you about to take that foul you're  better off just letting them have the  layup  the crowd upset the buck's upset  booker's still in the game and it's a  one-point lead for phoenix  that's a foul  but giannis antenna sting with the play  backs it home  and you're absolutely right mike that  the hustle i mean the foul is clear  he tried to take it but giannis not  giving up on the play  cuts the lead to one